in the distant future we may have the
technology to actually enter and pass
through a black hole and maybe even
survive the journey
then we might finally answer the
question what lies at the heart of a
black hole some scientists believe we
could use black holes as a kind of
portal with the potential for travel
across the universe this is still very
speculative but the mathematics seemed
to indicate that as you fall through a
black hole that you don't simply die you
fall right through a wormhole which is a
gateway a shortcut through space and
time
perhaps we can simply rock it across the
universe through a subway system that we
call a black hole
if black holes are shortcuts through
space and time it could turn one of the
coolest ideas from science fiction into
reality time travel is possible but not
very practical you see the energy source
the material that you need to keep the
throat of wormhole open is something so
exotic that we cannot produce it in the
laboratory but if you could it might be
possible to exploit the power of black
holes to visit yesterday perhaps our
descendants in the future have already
mastered this technology so one day if
somebody knocks on your door and claims
to be your great-great-great
great-great-great granddaughter don't
slam the door